[Music]
so
it is seven o'clock good to see you this
morning rishi's rewiring is what the
chancellor is calling it he's about to
reveal a plan for financial firms to get
greener and transition to net zero but a
warning this morning from the un's
special envoy on climate action mark
carney who told us that it's not easy
and that one of the main problems is
that banks that finance the fossil fuel
industry well under the chancellor's
plans companies in charge of around 40
percent of the world's financial assets
will align themselves with global
climate goals
greenwashing where companies say they're
doing more to protect the environment
than they actually are
will be guarded against
and rishi sunac will reveal plans for
the uk to become the world's first net
zero financial center
let's head straight to glasgow but of
course the cop 26 sum continues our
correspondent ashland hernandez is
standing by ashna lovely to see you this
morning we'll take us through what we're
going to be hearing from the chancellor
a very good morning to you yes it's
going to be all about cash today
throughout this whole conference so far
we know it's been a bit of a balance
really between cash and climate
commitments those developing nations
really wanting more money from those
bigger richer nations and today the
chancellor rishi sunak is going to be
taking a center stage and saying that he
wants the uk to become the central
financial uh center he says he wants to
combine big uh businesses big uh
institutions like universities civil
society groups and other industry
regulators to bring them together and
make them make some very serious
commitments about the climate going
forward but more importantly the money
that's going to be pumped into it as i
mentioned it has been this toss-up so
far between these climate commitments
these promises from these nations lots
of dates being thrown around india
taking go hoping to go net zero by 2070
china by 2060 and this whole whole i
guess the reason we're here today is to
talk about the money behind that how
much is being pumped into those
developing nations to help them get
there as quickly as possible um these
plans that rishi is going to announce
which is going to announce is going to
be about high level targets we're
hearing more on that from the minister a
little bit later on but leaders have
headed home now after this barrage of
announcements that they made over the
last two days yesterday we saw billions
being invested on in deforestation the
idea of restoring the rainforest in the
forest not only in norway but places
like indonesia and brazil as well
yesterday we also heard announcements on
clean technology how the uk is going to
be um fronting that but also the us and
china deciding they're going to take a
state center stage with that
announcement too but hopefully today it
will be all about the money
actually thanks very much indeed
uh let's get the view of our business
correspondent helen ann smith is here in
the studio morning helen ann um look i
suppose there is an issue if you are
going to be going after financial
centers like the united kingdom and
their their investment in you know
fossil fuels and so on well it's part of
the raise on detroit isn't it for banks
to chase the money and there is still
plenty of money in this yeah that's
exactly right i mean it's a real
recognition i think from the chancellor
today and others gathered there that if
you don't tackle the money it's going to
be really difficult to tackle the bigger
problem because while there's money
still to be made uh organizations will
as you say chase that money and in terms
of sorting out the money it's not just
as ashamed was saying they're getting
money to some of those developing
economies but it's also cleaning up the
money uh that exists in financial
centers like here in london it's about
making sure that money is not going
towards things like fossil fuel
companies deforestation to make sure it
is going towards things like greener
cleaner energy now there was a few
things today neil so i'm just going to
unpack them firstly let's take a look at
the glasgow financial alliance for net
zero very casually named what it is a
collection of banks financial
institutions investors they've
essentially agreed to come together in a
coalition to not uh finance the wrong
things essentially to align themselves
according to the rhetoric to those net
zero promises and there's a lot of the
world's financial assets that are
included under this 40
uh of the world's financial assets run
by about 450 companies that have all
agreed to be part of this the chancellor
also wants the uk to be the first
financial center to be aligned to net
zero he wants to start mandating that
companies publish their net zero
commitments where they've made them so
that this green washing we've heard so
much about can start to be gotten rid of
and then there's a chunk of money as
well to developing economies so lots and
lots there now climate uh campaign as
many of them are saying that this is all
well and good these announcements but
where they ask are the teeth to this
because although there's a lot of
commitments there's a lot not a lot of
mandating going on all of these
companies have agreed to be part of this
organization there's nothing to stop or
ban them from financing coal there is no
uh mandate to make a net zero promise
there might soon be a mandate to start
publishing what you're doing not a
mandate to make it in the first place so
a lot of people saying there needs to be
more regulation
to really uh control some of this
finance
thank you very much indeed more from you
later in the program but let's talk to
someone who
one hopes will know much more about it
than us uh john glenn the economic
secretary to the treasury uh joining us
from glasgow very good to see you this
morning minister um let's start with
just that which we were discussing with
helen ann take us through this plan for
the first net zero financial center
well we at paris six years ago we made
massive political commitments and
governments can provide billions but
financial services firms
can provide trillions
but what we want to do is actually give
people confidence in that journey to net
zero many have made that commitment to
net zero by
2050 but what today we're announcing is
that we will
get a task force together and in the
next 12 months
establish the regulations the journey
the the pathway to deliver that and the
milestones and conditions that people
will need to display in order to give
credibility to those goals that will
make us the first jurisdiction in the
world to have that net zero uh
obligation for financial uh services and
we're a massive financial services
center in london and uh it's important
that we take the lead globally on this
matter
indeed it is i just suppose the the
question as i was discussing with helen
ann is where the level of compulsion is
towards those institutions that
that in the past have benefited from on
the one hand at talking up their green
credentials but you know take for
example barclays bank they've financed
5.6 billion dollars worth of new fossil
fuel projects since january more than
more than any uk other uk bank so where
does the pressure come from aside from
public pressure
well there's enormous pressure to be
accountable to those goals that they've
committed to and i think we need to
recognize that this is about a
transition it's an urgent transition
but it's clear that we can't
immediately overnight
stop investment in some sources of
energy but what we need to have is a
credible way of measuring the transition
to net zero which many of these firms
covering 130 trillion of assets have
committed to and if you look at what the
committee on climate change says they
recognize that though we're moving
rapidly to renewables there will need to
be this transition what we're announcing
today will give credibility to that
transition journey for those firms that
control that massive amount hundred and
thirty trillion of the world's assets
uh but but business
sorry if i'm repeating the question what
will we do if they don't live up to
commitments that let's be fair that they
have made in the past when becky jarvis
uh from the bank on our future it
describes it well it describes these
announcements as well commitments a mile
wide and an inch deep so there has to be
at some point some mechanism other than
simply public pressure by which we can
compel those financial institutions to
do that which they promise
well in the last 18 months we've seen a
massive increase in the commitments made
by
financial services firms
to make good on those to have
credibility as institutions there will
need to be
an agreed set of ways of reporting that
transition so within 12 months we will
have those plans ready we will then
legislate for them in order that people
can have confidence in the journey that
these firms are speaking to because i do
recognize the skepticism that exists and
it's of course no good if people are
claiming to get to net zero by 2050 but
there's no credible information that is
verifiable on that journey
that will be what we will be working on
and that will be people from academia
from ngos
from industry from government regulators
to get this right and that's what we'll
be working on over the next 12 months
what does all this mean for the for the
tens of thousands potentially actually
hundreds of thousands of people who work
in uh industries such as oil and gas and
of course the related services attached
to them
well we know that we've got to
transition
urgently to net zero but we also know
that in the interim we will have some
degree of reliance on
the the
less clean energies and what it means is
that those firms that employ many people
are actively engaged on that journey to
transition so if you take companies like
bp they're using their profits to adapt
their businesses to serve the renewable
imperative in the years ahead they're
doing that urgently and what today's
about is giving some confidence around
how those plans
are actually put into milestones that
lead to the outcomes that they are
aiming for
how does this square with the the
freezing of fuel duty the cutting of air
passenger duty for domestic flights last
week it seems on the one hand
talking up our commitment to getting to
net zero as soon as possible but on on
the other hand you know making it easier
for people to continue to pollute
well we did
freeze fuel duty for the 12th year in
succession last week because we also
have to recognize the pressures that
exist
on families in their everyday living
government has to take a range of
decisions and that's what the chancellor
did we made some changes to the domestic
apd but we also introduced an increase
to the super long haul for the longer
flights so
we have to balance these decisions but
make no mistake this government is
committed to that net zero goal we were
the first country to legislate for to go
net zero by 2050 and today's plans are
about actually giving that pathway that
people can have confidence in but
government has to make you know complex
decisions at every fiscal event and we
need to do the right thing by the
british people
what effect do you think this will have
on financial institutions in places for
example
like china and russia
well and you know china and russia we we
want them to make stronger commitments
you know this conference is about you
know getting a consensus on that journey
we obviously
want to do that by persuasion of course
we do and we hope that the the consensus
that is building that we had at paris um
will move them uh to make further steps
in due course but but what's important
too is that we in the united kingdom
show leadership and we show leadership
as a financial center in going to net
zero
rapidly uh with verifiable
plans and journeys for firms to
explain how they're going to achieve
that there is massive public appetite
for
the removal of green washing as a
concept and for people to be really
clear for firms to be really clear and
be accountable for what they're actually
doing and what they're investing in and
how they're going to achieve that net
zero goal by 2050.
indeed minister i wonder if we can turn
our attention to covet because quite
clearly the situation is not great as
regards as regards the virus this
morning
as things stand the euclid uk's weekly
death rate is three times the level of
other major european nations
hospitalizations
six times the rate on the continent the
uk has currently roughly as many daily
covert deaths as germany france and
italy put together when the prime
minister
was challenged by cnn's christian and
poor about the uk being the worst in
europe he said that he disputed that on
what basis does he dispute that
well the government is
monitoring the situation very carefully
we've obviously gone through a whole
journey in terms of dealing with kovid
we have announced the uh
need to have the booster and the need to
make those walk-in centers available for
people to
take that booster jab
sorry
but just in a simple statement of fact
what on what basis did the prime
minister challenge christine amanpour's
suggestion that we're the worst in
europe i've just given you the
statistics it seems pretty clear to me
well i think our vaccine rate and our uh
has been very impressive um in terms of
the the the trajectory of how things are
going to play out we're obviously
working with advisors from sage and from
health experts to look at what steps we
need to take and we monitor this very
carefully the imperative at the moment
is to get people to take these uh
booster jabs and ensure that we are
as prepared as we are for as we can be
um for the challenges that lie ahead
well there's at least one member of sage
that you're no longer working with so
jeremy fahrer has resigned his position
on that um we know that he was
advocating for
for vaccine plus in terms of the
strategy moving forward just just given
where we are in terms of
hospitalizations in terms of death rates
why are we not doing as as people like
sir jeremy farah have argued in the past
and moving to plan b immediately
well government discusses these matters
on almost daily basis there is a
committee of ministers that meet to
discuss this and
you know decisions will be
looked at on a rolling basis and
obviously there are a range of views and
you know further restrictions also have
consequences for people's lives as well
and so all of these things need to be
weighed up and we look at all advice
very seriously before we take very
serious decisions
so
at what point then
is plan b triggered i mean this is a
question that i've asked a number of
government ministers we've never really
had a clear answer on this at what point
do hospitalizations or the mortality
rate get insufferable so much so that we
move to plan b when does that
happen
well the data points vary across the
country and the
committees of government ministers that
need to discuss it take advice
from public health experts and the wider
health community as to what is the the
best way forward but it's there are a
number of uh things to consider with
respect to uh how we move forward and
those matters are under review
constantly
would it not be better then to be
absolutely crystal clear with the public
and explain to them at what point they
should expect and there is an
expectation building now the plan b will
come it's just when it comes that that
they would have a clear idea as to when
they should expect these further
measures to be reintroduced
well as i said the imperative for the
government at the moment is to get this
booster rollout accelerated so we can be
in a position
where
as many people are in the best place
possible we look at these things uh
across a number of data points and we
will make decisions in due course as as
we have done throughout this crisis
and i i wonder if we might talk for a
second minister um about your colleague
owen patterson who of course is uh has
been censored
by the sanders committee
what is the government's current
position we are told my court my
colleague tamara cohen has
just found this um the government is
going to have has concerns about the
standard system that they've been
bubbling away for a while
this is the straw that broke the camel's
back
is the party going to be supporting the
andrea ledson um amendment that would in
essence allow mr patterson to not face
the punishment to not face the censure
well forgive me i'm here in glasgow at
cop
i am aware of the concerns around the
process
of the
procedure committee and the
investigation that led to the
recommendation but this will be a matter
that my colleagues in parliament will be
looking at today
and
the amendment will be
discussed in due course in parliament
and it's a procedural matter for the
house of commons that's that's what's uh
we're talking about here over the
apparent fairness of the way that that
investigation was undertaken that's the
concern that i think
colleagues across the house have and it
will be examined in the house of commons
today
um but just in terms of of that process
indeed i spoke to um owen patterson back
in april on this program that in depth
in fact about the the suicide of his
wife
and his charitable efforts and frankly
it's an interview that will remain with
me for a very long time i'm very
sympathetic to the situation in which mr
patterson finds himself however
when you look at the committee report it
says this no previous case of paid
advocacy has seen so many breaches or
such a clear pattern of behavior and
failing to separate private and public
interest the committee was absolutely
certain of his guilt in all of this i'm
just wondering on what basis
the conservative government feels it is
appropriate to circumvent the
conclusions of that committee
well as i said it's a matter for the
house of commons to respond to that
report
and it's also a matter of concern around
the procedure leading up to that report
making those conclusions and i think
most people would agree that
when there is a dispute over someone's
conduct there's got to be fair and due
process
before an outcome and a determination of
the of the uh consequences is made i
think that's the area that the house of
commons
across all parties will want to look at
today
but just to pick you up you've mentioned
it a couple of times what and what what
is the evidence that the process has has
not been fair
well i mean the owen patterson has
made some
comments around what he experienced
through the course of a very long
investigation
and this will be something that the
house of commons will debate today but
please forgive me i'm here in glasgow at
cop um here to talk to you about the
transition to net zero i won't be in the
house of commons today and consequently
i i don't feel uh
equipped to give you a detailed readout
on that matter
minister well i hope you feel that we
did spend at least a few questions
talking about your brief thanks very
much for your time this morning
appreciate it thank you
let's bring in our political
correspondent tamara cohen who of course
has mentioned in that interview whilst
i'm live on air broke that particular
line i just tell us exactly what you
know tomorrow and
what we can make that which we heard
from the minister as he says he is in
glasgow this was it came up mid
interview but but frankly if he hadn't
been briefed on it i'd be very surprised
so what i understand at neil is that so
today mps will be voting on the
suspension of owen patterson the former
cabinet minister accused in that report
of this egregious case of paid advocacy
the standards commissioner who regulates
the behavior of mps has said so mp he
was recommended to have a 30-day
suspension which is a very serious
punishment and mps are due to vote on
that today now allies of owen patterson
have put forward an amendment an
alternative and what that says and
they're led by andrea ledson also a
former cabinet minister and an
influential figure they say let's pause
the decision on owen patterson while the
whole standard system is overhauled
because the key thing that john glenn
the treasury minister said there is that
there have been concerns about the
procedures for a while it's not just
this case i'm told that there have been
been concerns bubbling away for some
time about how these cases are looked at
and in particular how long
they take to rule on and the idea that
mps are not allowed to discuss them
while these long investigations are
going on so what andrea ledson is
suggesting is that they put the results
of that report aside for three months
while a senior conservative looks at how
the standard system is working and
overhauls it so the idea is that this
does not this motion does not decide on
the guilt or innocence of owen patterson
it just looks at how the whole standards
system is working now that attempt has
attracted 60 signatures already from
conservative mps all different kinds of
conservative mps not just
traditional allies of owen patterson so
it's obviously got a lot of support in
the conservative party and i understand
that the prime minister and the
government will be supporting it so i
think what we can expect today is the
government machine throwing its support
behind owen patterson and this idea that
the standard system needs to be
overhauled now labor have been saying
that this is an outrageous uh attempt to
to hope to overrule the independent
standards commissioner so i think we're
set for a big battle over this in
parliament today but the government it
sounds like throwing its weight behind
uh mr patterson
uh and tomorrow whilst we have you in
terms of that which we discussed with
the minister about what financial
centres heading towards net zero there's
a bit of detail there but the one thing
we we didn't get was well at what point
if they don't do what they say they're
going to do can we compel them to do it
yes i think it is a big moment that um
that there is that that financial
institutions have to um
have to publish what they're going to do
what they're going to do towards getting
to net zero in the past they've just
been allowed to say um we are getting
towards net zero without having to prove
anything so it is it is a big step but
of course the monitoring of of how they
do it will will be crucial but i think
um for rishi sunak to to announce this
step which i think he feels the uk
government is is leading the world on
that and it's something that mark carney
former governor of the bank of england
uh now now working in in the field of
climate change has called for uh they
will feel that this is a big step to be
taken at cop 26 today and they'll be
assessing the reaction from other
countries
tomorrow thanks very much
and let's continue uh discussing cop26
on course that which we had from the
minister with our business correspondent
helen ann smith i mean helen and we were
just talking once we're listening to
tomorrow there
it does come down to to an extent to the
idea of
how we will be able to enforce this i
mean we've had banks you know paris was
signed six years ago lots of banks
attended at that point made much of
their green credentials and then
continued to stick trillions of dollars
into fossil fuels yeah that's exactly it
and it's that lack of mandate the lack
of teeth if you like to some of these
proposals that's really been what a lot
of climate campaigners and others have
picked up on this morning to take for
example this glasgow financial alliance
for net zero that's the organization of
banks and financial institutions
gathered together by former governor of
the bank of england mark carney to
align themselves as he says to the
commitments of net zero that's all well
and good and it's very very positive in
a sense there's a huge
proportion of the world's financial
assets that will be contained under that
that controlled by the companies that
have signed up but there is no mandate
there's no regulation there's no actual
rules to say if you uh finance for
example a company involved in a
destructive agribusiness or
deforestation or a company uh involved
in fossil fuel production there is
absolutely no specific rules or
legislation to stop that or to bring any
sort of sanctions if a company were to
do that similarly at rishi sunak as well
you know wants to sort of bring forward
the mandating of companies publishing
their net zero plans and that is very
important don't get me wrong uh you know
they really want to tackle this issue of
greenwashing the issue of companies uh
making a few sort of
announcements that sound kind of green
and then still
kind of behaving in a way that's not as
green as they say it is and it's
important to tackle that but but a lot
of people are saying it's all well and
good mandating companies to publish
their net zero commitments but there is
currently no mandate at all for
companies to make a net zero commitment
in the first place so so you know it's
all positive of course and tackling the
money really really matters but just to
take an example uh just last month we at
sky news we did an exclusive story uh in
collaboration with an organization
called global witness about the amount
of finance that is still uh traveling
from centres like europe like america to
companies that are involved in
deforestation uh hundreds of billions of
pounds still channeling to companies
that fund deforestation despite many of
these banks having anti-deforestation
policies so just a small example about
how much work there is still to do yeah
for the time being at least greed rather
than green appears to be good doesn't it
helena thanks very much indeed
well in his speech this morning rishi
sunak will say that he wants to rewire
the entire global financial system for
net zero but how will that work in
reality well let's head uh speak to
ashish joshi joining us from the
maldives and i actually where are you on
we've been listening to your coverage
all this week from from the beaches and
the islands of mauritius what what do
they need to ensure their long-term
survival and indeed do the financial
markets
crop up in their discussions
finance crops up in discussions a lot
there's
been a few times when i've spoken to
senior ministers and governments here
and they have reiterated their need for
access to funds the 100 billion dollars
that was pledged six years ago
in paris simply hasn't been made
available to developing nations we heard
the prime minister boris johnson talking
about the most vulnerable low-lying
islands that need desperate help and you
can't have really a better example than
here in the maldives they rely
so heavily on tourism it's 30 percent of
their gdp we've been through a pandemic
when tourism stopped they've taken a
massive hit on their own finances here
in this country and all at the same time
they have to keep looking at how they
shore up their coastal defenses that
takes a lot of money they have to
reinvest now in the tourism sector to
encourage tourists to come here they are
expanding the airport they are building
new resorts they have to because that is
what drives the maldivian economy it
would be foolish to think that that
would have to stop because there are
countries around the world who can
manage both who can still have green
economies and still grow their gdp as
well as having a vibrant tourism sector
and that's what the maldives needs so
when i speak to people here they say
it's really difficult because we need to
spend money on protecting our islands
building up the the infrastructure
around to make sure that our coral reefs
which are suffering severe degradation
are protected they are worried about
rising sea levels they have to
compensate
families and farmers who are affected by
rising sea levels people who lose their
homes are under threats of relocation
they've got to find other places for
them to live there are schools along the
shoreline which need help as well so
they look at glasgow and they'll know
that they want more money but they want
access to this money too
ash is joshi in the maldives not
mauritius i know you get around but it's
definitely the maldives thanks very much
indeed uh let's bring in neville lazarus
who is in delhi for us this morning and
of course narendra modi heading back
there having made a pretty significant
commitment but not a commitment that
goes as far as many would have wanted
that's right net zero by 2017 20 years
beyond the international deadline but
it's also his he's also committed to
some other uh major commitments uh one
was that uh all uh 50
of uh india's energy by 2030 will come
from non-fossil fuels an increase
of about
500 gigawatts of renewable renewable
energy also by
2030. now these are very big and
ambitious plans which have a are very
big in scale and scope and there is a
lot of
opportunities for
technology companies and and green
technology to come and invest in this
country that is what also the
government's looking for uh he is also
fighting the corner for developing
countries in terms of finances and and
transfer of green technology which
developed countries have pledged uh
india is a vast country the net the grid
network is uh is quite broken there are
the finances are in shambles
and there is a lot of scope for
improvement out there this mainly due to
electoral politics where subsidies are
given for uh for votes but uh prime
minister modi putting his
putting himself on the forefront in
front of world leaders talking about his
commitment he has a majority in
parliament he is known to be a strong
and decisive leader he has taken some
unpopular decisions uh
which
which has has created some sort of
political backlash in this country for
him but he has not uh he has not wavered
from them and a lot of
a lot of leaders will be looking at at
that
for him adoring to all the commitments
that he has made now
india has also and he himself has often
spoken about how india has been on track
to the paris agreement targets and is
going beyond that he is investing a lot
in renewable energy uh particularly in
the solar sector but he will be held
accountable and india will be held
accountable to all the commitments that
they have made neville thanks very much
indeed
a little bit of breaking news reaching
as uh and it regards the ongoing harvest
this discussions between the british
government and the french over fishing
uh we've been hearing from the french
transport minister sounds like a bit of
good news he says this that the uk has
shown a constructive spirit regarding
the talks over brexit and indeed fishing
licenses we'll dig a little bit into
that bring you more after this
[Music]
welcome back it is day three in the cop
26 meeting in glasgow and there have
already been a number of announcements
so are the politicians making meaningful
progress uh someone i'm sure with a view
on this tom rivet carnac previously the
chief political strategist for the paris
agreement at the un tom great to see you
uh this morning before we kind of delve
into the announcements that have already
been made just a question of procedure
given your experience with paris now
that the leaders have left is this when
the real work starts to get done
well in many ways that's true although
the last two days have been critical i
mean world leaders have been here
biggest gathering of world leaders since
the paris agreement six years ago it's
been a remarkable signal of political
intent and actually what was critical is
before they left alok sharma the cop
president spoke to the world leaders and
he said you had you have to leave your
ministers and your negotiators with a
strong mandate to now go forward and do
the work to find the agreements
necessary that's really important he did
that because what that means is there's
now enough latitude left here in glasgow
to actually reach agreement where we
have to well on the basis of that which
we have heard so far i mean what is what
has been the personal highlight for you
well i mean i have to say i've gone on a
bit of an emotional roller coaster i
think when we started on sunday looking
at the g20 i felt pretty anxious there
were some statements coming out that it
didn't go far enough we didn't get that
clear clarion call that actually made me
feel sure that we were going to get to
where we wanted to but a few days later
i'm actually feeling much better i mean
we've seen leaders come out and actually
recommit to 1.5 degrees as a threshold
remember coming out of paris we said two
degrees with best efforts to 1.5 we're
now sharpening that to saying it has to
be 1.5 and we know that's the case from
a scientific perspective and beyond that
i'd say there's been three things that
have been really critical the first
thing is that there has been new net
zero commitments from countries like
india and a range of others that now
means that 89 of global emissions are
covered by a net zero target that's
amazing that's up from just around 50 at
the beginning of this year that's huge
progress the second thing is these big
commitments on deforestation we have
tried for years to integrate
deforestation into the climate debate
you can't solve climate without stopping
deforestation yesterday we saw a real
moment of clarity i would say the
beginning of the end of deforestation
100 countries committing to end and
reverse it by 2030 with some very clever
market mechanisms partnerships with the
private sector to make that happen and
the third thing is in methane i mean it
doesn't sound that exciting but reducing
methane is in a way the best way well it
absolutely is the best way that we can
avoid global heating in this decade and
there are 105 countries have come
together to make a commitment to really
take action we're not there yet it's
only day three and there's a long way to
go but i'm feeling much better than i
did two days ago
and well allow me to inject a dose of
cynicism into all of this then you
mentioned india a second ago and of
course their their commitment to being
uh to me net zero by 20 70 we've also
heard from the chinese 2060
significant steps forward clearly but
isn't that because of where they started
rather than than where they're going i
mean is it enough for india one of the
biggest polluters in the world to be
talking about 50 years from now
it's a great question and obviously it
isn't enough like so much in climate
change it's transformative it's
remarkable and it's nowhere near enough
and it can only be a beginning so what
we saw from india was the first time
they put on the table a net zero goal
2070 i agree it's a long way away it
needs to be brought forward but again if
you if you dig under that commitment um
by the end of this decade 50 of energy
coming from non-fossil fuel sources
there's been some analysis done already
that suggests that properly implemented
what that could mean is that india would
pique their emissions in this decade so
you're absolutely right it's not enough
and there's still a long way to go the
other reason that i would actually also
bring for a bit of cynicism based on
what i said at the beginning is
monitoring i mean particularly on the
deforestation commitment in 2014 there
was a big forest commitment made and
actually deforestation increased by more
than 40 over the coming years amongst
those countries that have made that
commitment so we have to approach this
with a degree of is this time really
different i think it is partly because
of the multitude of commitments that are
actually going to change this but also
because technology's changed we now have
satellites all around the world we can
basically tell when a single tree is cut
down that's going to make it much more
difficult to cheat on things like that
and ensuring that the payments for those
services come after the restoration and
the preservation has been made will also
be critical
apologies tom cynicism round two here um
haven't haven't we been here before i
mean you were involved with paris huge
historic agreement signed by the world
and then just a couple of years later it
it was in tatters it was in dust these
things can be incredibly fragile now
we're not expecting president biden to
sign it and then burn it just as soon as
he gets back to the white house that's
not the current incumbent's position but
you know things have a habit of falling
apart quite quickly
you're absolutely right they can do but
i would just challenge what you just
said in one specific way the paris
agreement sets him most in process um in
motion a process to completely transform
the global economy by 2050 right it's a
net zero goal by 2050 with a series of
five yearly commitments along the way
and i would say the experience of the
last few years actually shows how robust
it is the world's largest economy pulled
out for a few years no one else said
that they were going to pull out
everybody stayed in so what we're seeing
here in glasgow will not be enough to
guarantee us to stay to 1.5 degrees of
warming that's absolutely clear no
individual conference can do that what
it can do is keep 1.5 front and center
keep it on the table for us to move
firmly in that direction in the future
and ensure that in the coming years we
can really double down on those
commitments to get to where we need to
get
fair points all uh tom rivet carnet
great to have you on the program this
morning thanks for joining us
thanks so much
well as we've been hearing some key
deals have already been agreed in
glasgow they include that pledge by many
countries to cut methane emissions as we
were hearing the biggest contributor to
global warming well they say they're
going to cut those by at least 30
percent before the end of the decade but
it's how those promises are enforced in
places like texas home to much of
america's oil industry which will
determine just how successful this
summit is sky's u.s correspondent mark
stone reports from the permian basin in
texas
if america is to lead the way in cutting
emissions of a gas that's warming our
planet more quickly than any other well
then this is the front line the permian
basin texas
it's where the politicians promises in
glasgow meet the reality on the ground
look how big that player is
we're with sharon wilson and her team of
methane hunters for well over a decade
they've been exposing this invisible
odorless polluter and they are skeptical
now that change is coming
we pull up alongside one of the
thousands of oil facilities which dot
this landscape
and with a specialist camera sharon
shows us the problem
put it in high sensitivity mode
and if you want to just look
wow so you can't see anything
when you're looking with the naked eye
but as soon as you look through here
you can see you could see quite clearly
that there is vapor coming out of these
tanks
methane is a byproduct of oil extraction
and from the tanks holding the crude it
is seeping out the operators are allowed
to emit certain quantities of methane
but checks on what's actually happening
are lacks and so it is the imagery from
spot checks like this which sharon has
taken to glasgow to focus mines
at another site an unlit flare stack and
through sharon's camera the consequence
is exposed the flares are used to burn
off the gas so often though they are
partially lit or not a light at all and
so it's released into the air and you
can't see it
why haven't they lit it
i guess they don't have to
who's going to make them light it i've
been reporting it to the state every
time
at a third site more emissions from a
flare stack sharon's research with
others has concluded that 10 of flares
are not lit or are partially lit they
say this means companies here are
emitting up to three and a half times
more methane than was feared and here a
leak too
we approached the companies who operate
these plants only one responded saying
that they had found a leak on a tank
that they'd sold recently to another
operator
all this is a huge problem because the
scientists say that over a 20-year
period methane is 80 times more potent
at warming than co2
in short then it is a very very
significant contributor to our warming
planet and the hope from those who are
exposing the emissions is that they can
show us all the scale and the impact
good morning ladies and gentlemen
welcome to the permian basin
international oil show this is but up
the road in the local town a trade fair
hints at just how vital the oil industry
is to this community this is where the
biden administration's pledges to save
the planet are up against local politics
jobs and people
what is regulations going to do
i mean how do you regulate the climate
every business in this area whether it's
directly related to the oil field or not
is going to be
severely impacted if they shut any of it
down what do you think of climate change
i think it's [ __ ]
that's it
reducing methane emissions is a key
component of america's pledges in
glasgow sharon has taken her research to
scotland but she is not optimistic
the biden administration listens to the
industry more than he listens to the
people and he wants to be seen as this
compromiser
this big
negotiator
but we're past all of that we're past
compromising
it is so often the determination of just
a few to expose the damage done by so
many but this is a toxic political
climate exposure is one thing change is
quite another mark stone sky news in the
oil fields of texas
now cabinet ministers and senior
conservative mps are calling on the ecb
to take action into racism at yorkshire
county cricket club the chair of the
culture select committee wants the
entire yorkshire board to quit
after it ruled racially offensive
language used to its player as in rafiq
was simply banter let's get more on this
nice guys shaman freeman powell joining
us from the newsroom morning shaman take
us through the story
what exactly
is the position of the yorkshire cricket
board
good morning well this is a story that
has been rumbling on for quite some time
now but as you said those senior
politicians speaking out has made it a
big story for this morning so just for
context azim rafiq spoke out about his
experience at yorkshire county cricket
club more than a year ago now he spoke
about bullying that he experienced as
well as what he described as deep rooted
racism and said that at one point it got
so bad that he was close to suicide now
there's no denying that this took place
the club admitted that it happened and
even apologized but quite bizarrely it
seems that they put the racist slurs
down to banter and no disciplinary
action has been taken and i think this
is what's really angered people as you
say nadine doris who is the secretary of
state for digital culture media and
sport has spoke out she says that zen
rafiq's treatment after the racism he
faced was disgusting she added that the
investigation that followed only makes
it even worse and that the as she tagged
the ecb which is the governing board
body for cricket in england and wales
and said that an investigation must be
swift and fully transparent and it
clearly bothered
sadie javid too he tweeted that the
racist language that he experienced was
not banter and called for heads to roll
at yorkshire county cricket club
and so the ecb has since responded after
azim rafiq commented about how long it's
taken and has apologized but it's yet to
be seen whether this is a strong enough
response as i said no discipline
reaction has been taken yet
well we will see sherman thanks very
much indeed
still we are coming up after the break
i'll be finding out how greece has
managed to keep its tourism industry in
business despite the global pandemic
[Music]
the worst floods to hit western europe
in a generation rate of deforestation
time is running out to halt the climate
crisis by nature two months of rain in
just two days we see the effects more
and more the house block after
a global problem which requires a global
solution a long dangerous summer
stretches ahead cop26
full coverage
on sky news
we've been uh cutting carbon for two
decades in actually i joined google in
2007
i was a child really and in those days
we went carbon neutral and then since
then what we've been doing is investing
heavily in renewables so 2017 we matched
all of our electricity purchases
globally with renewable energy with a
bigger big investor in wind and solar
and so on and we've announced our plan
to be carbon free only operating on
renewables by 2030 in our campuses and
data centers good news is
in two or three data centers in europe
we're already running only on renewables
over 90 of the time so we're getting
towards that the last 10 is hard but i
think it's a really important thing for
people to understand every time you
search or watch a youtube video you're
already carbon neutral and we're well on
the way to being carbon free we're
trying to help users make smarter
choices too so one of our pledges is to
help a billion users
using our products in their everyday
lives to make smarter choices for the
planet so good example there is google
maps probably the most useful thing we
can do is show you the most eco-friendly
route and we're doing that and so if the
most eco-friendly route is very similar
in time to the rest we'll just give you
that if it's a bit of a difference in
time we'll show you the option because
sometimes you'll be able to make that
choice and we estimate that we could
take the equivalent of 200 000 cars off
the streets uh if people are using those
kinds of tools or when you search for a
product or a flight or a hotel we want
to be able to show you the more
eco-friendly options so that's one of
the ways that we can help consumers make
smarter choices and by the way we know
that people really care over 70 of
people in countries around the world
care about and are fearful of the
consequences of climate change and
that's why it's so urgent that we take
action it's clear that governments and
companies and communities need to work
together to do this and that's why
google's trying to play its part
we're one of the world's biggest
purchasers in the corporate sector of
renewable energy we invest we're often
the first investor in things like a wind
or a solar farm so that we bring new
capacity online that others can benefit
from what we've found is actually by
doing that we've reduced our energy
costs you know these new renewables can
be as cost efficient
as older types of energy and i think one
of the key things at cop is for
governments to give that framework for
decarbonisation
for more finance to help to assist that
transition transparent carbon markets
and to incentivize innovation
[Music]
[Applause]
uh welcome back uh if you've been
watching since the top of that you'll
recall i was speaking uh to the
government minister this morning doing
the rounds about owen patterson
conservative mp currently facing censure
let's bring in our uh political
correspondent tamara cohen to try and
flesh out a little bit more of this
story now tomorrow there was
there is to be a vote to walk us through
exactly what is happening today it's all
to do with an amendment uh being put
forward by by andrea ledmond i think
yes owen patterson the former cabinet
minister was heavily criticized in a
report last week for breaking the rules
on paid lobbying when he was a
consultant for two private companies and
the standards commissioner who
investigates these sort of claims
recommended that he be suspended from
parliament for 30 days which is a really
big deal actually because it could lead
to a by-election in his constituency and
him no longer being an mp so mps are
voting on that today and allies of owen
patton are really coming to his defense
including andrea ledson who is an
influential conservative herself former
cabinet minister who has put up an
amendment supported by a lot of
conservatives and i can tell you today
supported by boris johnson and the whole
government which would put aside a
decision on owen patterson's case while
the entire standards system is
overhauled and replaced by something
else a different committee which would
have a conservative majority and as you
can imagine labour have been pretty
outraged saying that this takes us back
to the bad days of tory sleaze so big
row in parliament coming up
yeah and we've got uh labour's listen
andy coming on the program in just a few
minutes time so i'm sure to be putting
that to her thanks very much tamara
well despite the pandemic and a global
economic downturn greece is one of the
few countries which has kept its tourism
industry in business official figures
show that visitor numbers there were
down just 35 percent and a complete
recovery is expected by next summer i
will let's speak now to vasilis kikilas
the greek minister of tourism minister
great to have you on the program and i
suspect given that which i've just
shared that which i've just said you're
quite pleased to be the minister of
tourism for greece at the moment
correct mr patron thank you very much
for the invitation
i was the minister of health for the
previous two years within the pandemic
it was a huge huge fight for us but we
were transparent organized our health
protocols gave predictiveness and
the results paid off and yes
checking out the english market
tour operators airline companies
influencers from the
uk and the travelers
we we we're looking at the total come
back in in 2022 which is very important
for us because tourism is 25 of our gdp
it is absolutely remarkable particularly
if you hit that 2022 uh goal but
minister i i do have to ask have there
not been
any kind of knock-on effects from the
tourists from tourists coming in and out
of the country in terms of covert the
natural assumption would always be
that increased travel to and from a
country would lead to increased cover
transmission
well let me tell you that we took a
calculated risk back in 2020
and
[Music]
against maybe all loads the rest of the
mediterranean countries did not open for
tourism we did
with enhanced testing multiple testing
we send
nhs workers multiple nhs workers to our
islands we had guaranteed hotels private
physicians and doctors linked to our
hotels
we did pcr tests and rapid tests we
organized it and it paid off so yes of
course a huge difficulty
because it's a pandemic it's a global
huge crisis of public health but
i feel that if you're transparent and
you're organized and you have you have a
vision and
you trust people to work with you then
that that pays off it wasn't easy and of
course there are always obstacles
it's not on the automatic pilot not at
all but we're confident and it's not
just us this is there's there's huge
work behind that and let's not forget
that if we talk about the the english
market which interests us
a lot the english the british
are travellers they want to travel they
want to enjoy not just the sea sun and
sun but the beauties of other countries
and they're most welcome in greece
uh vasilis kikailis i'm afraid we aren't
going to have to leave it there we are
just about out of time but i just i
perhaps can just squeeze in very quickly
of course cop 26 going on at the moment
i mean is tourism and travel sustainable
in the longer term particularly for a
country like greece
that's a
basic part of our strategy already the
prime minister griez set out our islands
our touristic islands as green highlands
we started with fasting
he's visiting i am so sorry this is our
goal
minister i'm so sorry i can't read a
clock correctly we are going to have to
leave the interview there i really
appreciate your time and hopefully we'll
speak again in the future thank you
and we'll be back after this
[Music]